[Music]
in history and moderation news submitted
by the tuxedo an Instagram influencer
says kids shouldn't learn so much about
wardrobe - in school it's really hurts a
world war world war world stars will
start - I found it very easy MA I mean
great yes
Instagram influencer named Freddie
Bentley he went on good morning Britain
and he said in an interview that kids
should learn less about world war two is
too sad so bold I like this guy he
sounds like someone gets his ass kicked
oh yeah right so here's the quick 30
second clip of what he was talking about
it looks like it was in a hard situation
in World War two and I don't want anyone
to think I'm in disrespectful in that
way whatsoever
however I will stand by the point that I
don't think it's as educational the way
that we you know there's so many
problems going on in the world at the
moment like brexit that's not taught in
schools and and climate change which is
a situation that I feel like we should
be aware of and you know when I left
school I felt like it hit me like a ton
of bricks cuz I didn't know anything in
general run you say Mike you know how to
pay a mortgage or like all this stuff so
he's like so why did picking on World
War two of all the wars they're really
hardest feelings so negative he says I
don't think it needs to be in such a
young way to young children like
mentally mental health to be told this
certain amount of people died for you
I just learned as a child it's so
intense give her the Bible anything in
history at all so that's what people are
saying so then there was this other guy
that was there in the interview was I
was saying the other part where it's
like well this is a pretty important
part of our world history like 70
million people died and you know
this is this is teaching kids that there
could be other things that are worse in
your life like we've already gone
through a lot of trauma in our history
of the world but for him he's saying
yeah I'm not saying don't teach it at
all it's just like knock it down a
little bit it shouldn't take up so much
time of the education we should be
learning things that we can actually
apply actually feel the opposite I get
up when I finally found out in high
school that Christopher Columbus but
pretty much tell like the Native
Americans hey bring me gold oh you don't
have gold and we chopped her hands off
and your feet off and then you would
just straight-up just murder tons of
Native Americans I'm like why the [ __ ]
we reciting poems and singing songs
about him in elementary school
I'm like this guy's [ __ ] crazy honest
yeah I wish there was like history was
way more honest so we could actually
learn about it instead of I think this
honest part make made me not like
history because I'm just remembering
random facts with random dates that had
no emotional meeting and I don't know
what to take home message is there's no
story until later on like as an adult
I'm really interested in history now cuz
when I hear it I'm like also this caught
like X caused Y which cause Z this is
the lesson to learn don't don't do this
but I get it Bart Christian almost
wasn't perfect okay he does have a point
though where Christopher Columbus no no
Freddy Freddy Freddy Bentley what I also
think they should be teaching us a lot
more practical knowledge to agree but
let's get rid of mass love marry gonna
tax class I like a more applicable mess
yeah couple man instead of like my
trigonometry or whatever I don't need to
know what this triangle the degrees of
all the triangles I don't need that I
know unless you're gonna be like a
carpenter and then fine you have to take
all those classes not me true so mad
when I got to college and I was like I'm
gonna be a writer I don't need any
science and they're like no sorry but
she you still need general education
science I'm so mad I was like what do we
need bio for I'm in college towel you go
write about animal
you can write about um sci-fi oh you
know specifically there you go yeah
that's why I dropped out of the whole
thing altogether I was updated I'll need
this I'm grown a year but it was all
that was like general ed and stuff and I
just felt like college is meant to
prepare you for your career so why
wouldn't I just go straight into like I
don't think any college unless you're
gonna like Juilliard prepares you for an
acting career especially television I
did a semester of college before I was
like yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm just doing
UCB and stuff but I did a semester of
political science and I went in there as
a satirical character who thought that
the Iraq war was the dopest things I've
ever and everyday I would just defend
the [ __ ] out of the Iraq war and how
we're blowing the [ __ ] out of the lease
and I was like this is so tight and good
and like we need the surge because we
need to be blowing the [ __ ] out of these
countries so that they're not here
blowing the [ __ ] out of us but people oh
no they'd know everyone was [ __ ]
pissed Lee who's that it was awesome my
teacher he he got what I was doing cuz
he he was smart like then yeah he was
smart guy but I wish I knew you know he
liked that he liked all that he liked my
message oh yeah so Freddie here he got a
ton I hate he's just like everyone was
really felt very that he was being very
disrespectful pretty much and so he also
sounds like he wants to put like small
pillows at every corner of every table
well you know every just make the whole
world just a little bit safer if the
whole world to be this much safer way
better just a little bit sugar until all
lemons please cuz he said I don't think
encouraging death or telling how many
people died in in a world war is going
to help anyone his problem is he should
I like the idea of like let's teach more
practical stuff in school but he
shouldn't have singled out one war that
was like against
a particular race of human-like dude you
need to I don't know choose a different
just be like history let's teach less of
it right he's gonna be so specific about
one it makes him look good well plus I
think in if if people the people
fighting in World War two knew that it
was they were actually saving the Jews
they all might have been like I don't
know cuz back then everyone was pretty
[ __ ] like weird about Jewish people in
just a minute
like everyone yeah yeah yeah all over
the place really yeah cuz it's not like
they were like it's like every country
knew they were saving the Jews they
didn't find out till later every coach
has their own agenda exactly like the
Russians weren't in it to save the Jews
like they were in it because they were
helping us take out the Germans because
they felt the Germans were that they
thought they were right so they're just
allies it's for like it's a game of
Thrones our only allies for the sake of
their own yeah yeah yeah yeah no nobody
was doing it altruistically to save the
Jews like that's that's kind of the
whole there's still 70 million people
that died over it that like know for
sure but that's like so that's like how
we say that we were in civil war
distends Lavery like not not not really
like I had mostly to do with the south
mouth feeling represented and to save
like the national economy right that's
more of a money thing exactly a lot of
the farming stuff that was going on
around then but the slavery was like a
byproduct of that like Lincoln freed the
slaves like have like to kind of [ __ ]
the South seek on me it's kind of like
now we're like in politics what I don't
like is this a bunch of emotionally like
gets people's emotions up and then
they're there's all these hidden agendas
that are happening behind the scenes
they know so probably a civil war
they're like oh man the north took away
your slaves so you should vote with us
and you should help us fight when really
it's like they have their own agenda
they just know what are the hot-button
issues to get people to do their job of
that time I mean the good guys there's
not a good guy dude it's you you're you
are you are sucked you were just looking
at one side of the orange no I'm a
parent my mom went to a trump rally
no no but it's okay so that's what I'm
saying so so okay that's exactly it open
you're looking but
you're talking about one side of the
orange I'm talking about how there's
just one giant political party that
agrees on everything like spy on all of
us go to war against every [ __ ]
country like like have the CIA in all
countries like and then we all just kind
of focus on little tiny things that are
superfluous I want every I want to be
spied on I want there to be no you see
all those two crime documentaries but
they're like this guy was in the wrong
place at the wrong time if only there
was camera footage everywhere record me
like I want this to come up and save my
life one day oh boy
see I think you're a good girl for the
media I think you're a good girl for the
whole war economy reptillian mean like
you plugged here by them to like the
implant in everyone's mind that we
should be recorded this is why we should
teach history because Iman one of the
arguments some good spice lattes a lot
this is why we should buy them this
exactly did you sorry because the brown
shirts in Nazi Germany who were spying
on fellow citizens they would say I have
nothing to hide what do you have
something to hide you don't want you
don't want me to be in the room right
now you have something to hide like
what's your deal I wanted to protect
myself no I know but that's what I'm
saying that from people who are gonna
try to use information to put me away
but that's looking at one side of the
orange you think they're there to see
the brown shirts will take advantage of
someone like you mm-hmm
but there's footage of these information
against you yeah follow your party you
should watch Edward Snowden on Jill
Rosen pretty it's almost like I haven't
thought this through I've been there
girl and literally there's too many
sides to the course it's all enjoy our
Starbucks cup that's right Christmas
coats there's two different kind well
good I'm happy again and couldn't see in
there a demo site but yeah so I mean I
agree and then the fact that this kid
came at it where it was like you know
it's just like for mental health like
these kids can't handle that much trauma
and like that much graphicness of like
everyone that died it's like okay now
you lost me there is a weird that I just
want to hear him talk about things cuz I
like the way he talks now it's no big I
think we all agree on though they should
keep more
it's cool thing but but but the whole
don't teach about history thing is
that's a little scary
[Music]